i know some of you are looking at this
and thinking yeah where do i go with
this
let me give you a bit of a steer
hopefully in a helpful
direction similar tasks that we have to
begin with
but slightly different information we
need to begin by finding a vector
equation of a line we've got
a point that the line l goes through
3 2 6. and so immediately that's
actually this is example 2.
this is actually the first piece of
information i want that point that i
go through line l goes through 3 comma 2
comma 6 what does it represent
in my vector equation of a line
3 2 6 which part of this vector equation
is it
it's the it's the position vector i've
got to get on to the line so i'm going
to begin just by saying 3
2 6. ta-da i'm on the line now right
then i need to know which direction i am
facing with and again
the question hopefully tells us but you
need to sort of see through which
bit is relevant can anyone help me out
you know two choices 50 50 if you're
really just guessing
the direction vector i want here right
is going to match
or the easiest way is just to match the
direction vector of the other
line which in this case is negative 3 1
2.
so again i want to draw that parallel
that the
the syllabus hopefully does to saying if
we had just straight lines on a
cartesian plane right
this is very analogous to you know y
equals
m x plus b right where
this gradient here is very similar to
our direction vector and if i ask you to
find two parallel lines
you just ignore the y intercept because
it's irrelevant right where are you
doesn't matter which way you're facing
that's the part that's important so i
have my vector
equation of my line i just had to read
off the relevant information
then we have to do a bit of thinking
right find the corner to the point where
l meets the x y plane and it's the xz
plane is the other one we're interested
in okay
now um there's two ways to go about this
if you've gotten to a point of
excuse me fluency you can just say
there's a value i need to substitute in
and my numbers will come out right if
you're at that point
good for you but for the rest of us who
are kind of like wait what's the
where do i go have a think about maybe
be helpful to you if you did not
immediately see
morgan i think you might already know
where to go and i'll come to that in a
second
draw yourself a little you know
three-dimensional coordinate system
right just so we can understand even if
you do know exactly what the next step
is why the next step is what it is
where is the xy plane on this diagram
the xy plane that's the first one we're
doing it's the one you
it is actually helpful to do this with
your hands isn't it right it's the one
that i guess you could say is lying
flat on the ground as we look down at it
right so i'm just going to show you in
here
this guy here is the x
y plane now think about this with me
if you are on the x y plane excuse me
any of our any value of x is allowable
you can move freely
in x and any value of y is also
allowable you can move freely in y
what you're not allowed to move in is z
right you're kind of locked in
down on the ground as it were and
there's a z value
that goes with that right to find
our x y our intercept to the x y plane
which i guess we would call our x y
intercept
right morgan you want to tell me what
value we should actually take on
so to find the um let that be zero
okay fantastic we're about to do this
just shortly but i just want to again
draw this parallel to all the things you
know in the cartesian plane
if i asked you to find a y-intercept
intercept with the y-axis what would you
instinctively do without even thinking
about it
you would sub in for the y-intercept
you'd find x equals zero
right well that's exactly what you're
doing here do you see this it's like
these
are the axes along which i can move so
that those values are variable
but this is the axis on which i can't
move so that's why it's fixed let's z
equals zero so when you go ahead and do
that what do you get
if z equals zero that gives you have a
look
i'm going to try and find an appropriate
lambda here right and here
here's my values that correspond to z
right so i'm going to get what am i
going to get 6 plus
2 lambda so what i'm getting for my z
component
that's going to equal 0 because that's
what i've set right and from here i can
say well therefore lambda equals
negative three okay i'm so happy at this
point that you guys know what to do i'm
even just going to hit pause on that you
can take that value of lambda and you're
going to pop it into x
you're going to pop it into y and you'll
get what did we get
12 negative one zero yeah so this is
going to dot dot dot
12 negative one zero when we substitute
into the x component
when we substitute into the y component
don't bother substituting the z
component please why
because you already did that right well
you this is your assumption right um
though if you wanted to test
go ahead and make sure you found the
right lambda i put it back in you're
like oh i didn't get z equals zero
something's gone wrong
by analogy what am i going to do to find
the x is it the x z intercept
i can't remember x z right to find the x
z intercept
what will i substitute yeah fantastic
let y equal zero by the way please note
please note even on whiteboard working
which i'm quite happy to skip a few
things because i know you know what i'm
doing
please note what i do not write here i
don't just write
y equals 0 and then start doing some
arithmetic tell me what on earth you're
doing
every single vector equation of a line
has three equations hiding underneath it
and then every time you substitute you
make a new one
right so if you're going to say y equals
zero tell me why you're doing that
why you're doing that and then your
working can actually be read in a
meaningful way
once you do that what do you get i think
there's is there a 9 in there
nine i already knew the y was zero and
then
two that's what we're going to get out
of this make sense
okay i hope that clicks for you i
promised three examples so here
is the last one let me guide you through
this a little bit
and then we'll see how far you can get
on your own we're given two
vector equations of lines um it used to
weird me out that they're both called
r and then i realize wait a second we do
this all the time right if i said to you
oh here's a parabola y equals x squared
and here's some other line y equals 2x
minus one
find points of intersection we have no
problem calling one y and the other one
also y same deal here okay so both
equations
r equals this and r equals that now
there's some language here we just have
to be a bit cautious of right
by equating components that's not
something that
comes up explicitly in our syllabus at
least it doesn't anymore
but we've been doing this kind of
implicitly the whole time through what
it's implying is
you've got information about x in the
first equation you'd have
three plus lambda one that's all of your
x information yeah
the second equation you also have some
information for x it's uh
3 minus 2 lambda 2. do you see that
that's what i got from the x components
okay
if i'm finding a point of intersection
what can you tell me about the x
components of both those lines
they should match they should be equal
to each other right so that's going to
give us an equation
with lambda 1 lambda 2. you can do the
same thing for y
you can do the same thing for z that's
what they mean by equating components
i'm going to let you have a whirl see if
you can find that point of intersection
and uh when you go through that i just
want you to know there are actually some
strange curveballs hidden in this
question
that are not to do with getting the
answer but um the fact that
there's extra information that we sort
of don't need to get the answer
and so that's what i want sitting in the
back of your mind if you get this answer
quickly
if not i'll give you maybe three minutes
and we'll work through a solution
together
let me give you a bit of a hand i've
begun by having a look at as the
question suggested
the x component the y component okay so
you can see i've already started
um i equated the x component from the
first line with the x component from the
second one
and i got this and i've labeled it
equation one because i'm going to need
to use it in a second right
i do the same here at this point
what i'm trying to do is solve for
lambda 1 or lambda 2
and so i can just refer back to equation
1. so i guess the most
obvious substitution to make is let's
substitute that for
negative two lambda two yeah so i get
negative
four lambda two over here is that okay
yep
so i've got negative five plus lambda
two i guess i could subtract
lambda 2 and i should say by the way
i've done a substitution here so this is
from
1 right again show me where you got
these things from
and then subtracting lambda 2 from both
sides
i get this are you content
yep now at this point i mentioned i made
this reference to additional information
in the question
i wonder how many of you from here
instinctively said well
i had simultaneous equations i found one
unknown
guess i'd better find the other one now
i just want to hit pause on that thought
because have you noticed i don't need to
find
the other one why not like we always do
this simultaneous equations
two variables find both variables why
don't i need them
both in this case couple what do you
reckon
fantastic um these questions kind of
told you hey there is a point of
intersection there just there just is
one it's not asking whether there is one
this value here lambda 2 relates to oh i
didn't even write it down
it relates to the second equation right
and it fixes unambiguously
one point on that line if it is indeed
the point of intersection
it'll give me a point on the other line
right
morgan we're going to say something
similar to that or different um
yeah fantastic um you know this this
tells us there is that single point of
intersection
this value of lambda that'll give it to
us worth pointing out later on
we're going to have you know solving
things in three dimensions that are not
just lines
that will not just have a single point
of intersection so then you do need to
be cautious
but in this case i mean did anyone go
ahead and find out the appropriate value
of lambda one
yeah what was it minus negative two yeah
now it's not like this is worthless it
actually can be quite handy i asked you
guys like how would you know
whether this was whether you got the
right point of intersection
which was by the way what was it
negative was it negative one
five one negative i got my [ __ ] mixed
up one negative five
five how would we know because
presumably we get that from substituting
this into the second equation
how we know it was right one way is
we'll just have a look at the other
lambda
put it into the other line and sure
enough you get the same point okay
now we're actually not done quite yet
with our additional
information we can get what do we say
negative one
sorry one negative five five eventually
i remember it right
we can get this just from lambda one
right
we didn't need sorry lambda two is what
we started with we don't need lambda 1
there's even more information in the
question did you notice that we have not
even
touched have a look it's even on the
board
right what i used and what i didn't use
say it again yeah look at this i
inspected x
you created those components i inspected
y right
and i didn't even need this z
information why is it flying around
there
because you know there is a point of
intersection between two lines
so you don't really need to test it
again to show that there actually is a
point
that using the same lender very good joe
is exactly on the money if you didn't
quite catch that right
how do we go about solving this we
needed either lambda one or lambda two
so that's two unknowns you only need two
equations to solve for two unknowns so
the third one's just
kind of a bonus however if we did write
that kind of a bonus right what would
that z equation
look like can you equate them for me
what would the components be
seven plus lambda one yeah that's a
what's a what's a plus sign between
friends right
kind of a lot but that's okay what was
on the right-hand side what's uh
okay fantastic now what's lovely about
this is just have a look at this
equation now we've already got
a value for lambda 1 and 4 lambda 2.
does it work out
it better right uh what do we get over
here you'd get
five wouldn't you and then over here two
plus three
good to go what would happen what would
it mean
if for example because these zed
components not having looked at them
right
suppose the z component of the second
line
suppose it wasn't three suppose it was
something like
four what would that mean
think back to our very first question
today what would this
mean for us
i would have a lambda 1 and a lambda 2
that work for x they work for y but then
they don't work for z
in other words i've missed right now we
have a name for this when you've got two
lines
that just completely miss each other
not that they're in the syllabus but
they're called skew lines
s k e w skew
lines these lines that are not parallel
right but they never intersect in two
dimensions that doesn't happen
right in two dimensions if you've got
two lines that aren't parallel they've
got to collide somewhere
right but in three dimensions we've just
got lots more space to play with
right um which airline pilots around the
world are very thankful for all right
i'm going to hit pause there these three
questions they all take knowledge you
already knew
right but when you start to interact
with these points of intersection and
how the lines relate to each other
you've got to think quite carefully
about what you're doing with these
equations and why